[Applause]
welcome to the drew barrymore show
please welcome courtney cox david
arquette and matt campbell
i'm just so
excited i don't even want to pretend
like we are who we are i want to kick it
old school and get in a time machine and
go back 25 years and we're in santa rosa
california
i was 20 years old
wow tell me one thing that like no one
has ever
known or seen or heard something that's
like emblematic of that time you know
i was thinking of this yesterday and and
i was remembering a dinner that we had
at the wrap um
just after we'd wrapped we went to this
italian restaurant in santa rosa and we
all sat down around a table and everyone
got up one by one and talked about
how life-changing the experience was on
the movie
and yes there was like we felt had a
sense of lightning in a bottle on the
film itself but the experience for each
of us was
extremely meaningful um
so that dinner was kind of amazing i
remember some faint memory of us all
like a group of us all hanging out by a
tree
yeah it was right at the end it was like
right under a tree was that with the
bonfire because we did have a thing
yeah we were outside we had a bumper and
i actually remember i was talking i
can't remember who said it i think maybe
it was
matt might have said do you think like
do you think if this actually does well
that there could be a costume and we
were like nah
really do you think it cost you and now
i mean every year every halloween i open
the door and there's a ghost face at
some point i remember them coming back
like
it must have been right toward the
shooting beginning of the shooting and
like they had gone and found the mask
and they said they found it in the back
of this
toy store and weston like it near the
mass he was seeing he said do you have
anything old in the back like
under something and then they found the
mask
no way i don't remember that
and i had like the party room i had the
crazy party room where i had like black
light posters and things on the wall
lava lamps that everyone would come and
commute there
you're destined to hang out with each
other you can't just pop in and out it
was a real bonding experience for all of
us yeah we all became really good
friends and
um i mean right it was just and wes just
so wonderful and
all the producers were great we just we
were a big family for sure we became so
close courtney i remember at the poster
shoot i was like having a nervous
breakdown because i was having a false
sense of being pregnant i kept asking
you how do you know if you're pregnant
like i'm freaking out we're supposed to
shoot this poster but oh my god like i
just started dating somebody and i i how
do you know
i felt safe going to you like you were
the mature safe person in the room i was
an older one and i was the right person
to ask
i just i remember also being
like
so excited as an actor to do a scary
movie and i don't think there had been a
film like scream where it was such high
stakes and so terrifying and then like
campy and humorous
and a comedy at the next turn yeah also
just to
you know to kill off the iconic
drew barrymore in the first
segment of the film and it was 13
minutes or 14 was so powerful that you
knew they were going to take a chance
like that
that you just knew it was going to be so
just that's shocking to the audience
okay so courtney you're playing monica
on friends and then you get to come on
this film
what is it that you tell yourself or
like talk to us about where you're like
i want this to be different and this is
how
well i think that i had to
talk wes into letting me
do this i i definitely had a thing where
i needed to prove that i could be
you know
[ __ ] or you know
she was just
kind of ruthless but at the same time it
was it was we were kind of the comic
you know i was over the top so it was a
different kind of comedy
i don't know i just i loved it i i loved
all the
you know at each stream i would try to
come up with a different look for her
that was
just over the top gross or ugly or too
much whether it was
oh well that was the worst i don't wanna
i forgot about it
there's nothing worse but that was a big
lesson in life because that will forever
forever be on film and
i
we only had one set one set of bangs and
uh i remember they were cut on the set
you're supposed to have like a thing
that starts back here far back and
that's where the part goes for the banks
for some reason someone put it here and
started cutting and i went well i don't
have a choice now
okay i remember that day because we're
all like no they're good really the
highest boys
and here we are one of the most
successful iconic franchises in cinema
history congratulations to you guys
you know
that mask is iconic there's a new scream
like
how exciting is that
you know you know what's special is um
because of covid
the the younger cast the newer cast in
this film had a very similar experience
to ours they were all forced into one
hotel together they obviously weren't
spending time with anyone else outside
of the film so they were basically
isolated together
in the same way that we felt we were in
santa rosa and they had a very similar
experience they bonded they had a blast
they're big fans of this franchise so
that was really cool to see how excited
they were to be a part of these films um
yeah it's nice to see that oh yeah and
they're amazing act like really talented
kids so i gave them all a bob ross
painting lesson because i'm a certified
bob ross instructor so i bought them all
kits so we all sat around painting
together david every week course in
florida you can all become wonderful
what do you not do
right
um okay so are you guys
proud of this movie how do you feel
about the new directors who came in you
know picking up something so legacy like
nev from your perspective how do you
feel about this reboot great honestly i
think um
you know i'd been apprehensive about
jumping into this
when i'd heard it was being made just
because i think we all were a bit
nervous about making it without wes
because he's so responsible for the
mastery of these films and this
franchise
um but the directors matt and tyler sent
me a letter um prior to my accepting the
film
telling me that they actually were
inspired to make um ready or not their
other film by the scream movies and they
became directors because of wes craven
and that meant so much to me
um they said in the letter we're gonna
honor his legacy we you know we really
believe in his work and this is going to
be a genuine scream movie it's going to
be in that same vein and energy and at
the same level and we want to do right
by it i mean it was such a beautiful
letter
and they did it honestly they did it the
movie is great
fans are not going to be disappointed
and i'm really glad that i signed on to
this one
courtney what's it like from your
perspective
um it was really emotional when i walked
on the set and was felt like i was right
back in woodsboro but you know wes
wasn't there and it was just like oh god
i mean it was there was a lot of tears
all the time and when just feeling him
but
um like nev said the directors are
they're they were so kind and so
every single thing they did was in honor
of wes and
um
matt and tyler are just incredible
directors so i i enjoyed it and i just
love the the feeling of
bringing something back and knowing it's
going to be as good as the first and
different but still in the vein of
you know the class that it had i'm so
glad all right we'll be right back after
a quick commercial break with more
[Music]
you